uh and that leads to the desean watson
conundrum cal mcnair making it known
friday that desean watson is still a
texan and
we expect him to remain a texan now
there's two ways to look at this
this is either an effort to convince
anyone out there that the texans want to
try to keep him to drive up the trade
value
or they him even though he won't return
anyone's calls
and seems to be dug into the point where
he's not
showing up so the question then becomes
how long do they play this out do they
need to see it
happen do they need him to not show up
for the offseason program
for training camp for the preseason
whether to what extent there is one
for the regular season we know there
will be one do they need him to boycott
do they need to be in position to go
take money back from him do they need to
make him sit for all or part of a season
is this dwayne brown
who made it clear he was never playing
for the team again
and then was traded right before the
deadline you get less
if you wait until right before the
deadline to trade deshaun watson
than you would get if you get an auction
together now find out all the teams
desean watson is willing to
play for because he has a no trade
clause you can't just send him to anyone
find out the teams he'd play for and get
them all to the table
and you've got the desean watson
contract and start the bidding
that's the right way to maximize your
value
i don't know that they're thinking about
that i feel like they want to try to win
the tug of war and the problem is peter
if they lose the tug of war
they're going to get a lot less for
desean watson later than what they could
get for him now
they'll get a lot less for desean watson
later but not
certainly what happens if they hold out
all through this season
and he just sits all through the year
and next year the texans said well
can't get any worse for us unless we get
what we want which is four
ones and an established quarterback and
i'm making that up
i don't know what the what they would
want at the end
um but i keep thinking right now about
the new year
about the new york jets mike and and and
i'm going to get back to your point in a
second
i keep thinking about the new york jets
and my question is
what would happen right now if you're
the new york jets and you're joe douglas
and you say we'll give you sam darnold
we'll give you the second pick in the
draft
and we'll give you our one in each of
the next two drafts
and and the reason why that is a
different
kind of offer than virtually any other
team can make is that includes the
second pick
overall this year which means that if
you're the houston texans
you can keep sam darnold for a year
let's say and you can play him for a
year
and then you can judge by draft day next
year
whether you're going to need to go get a
quarterback
and what you do is you just save
basically
these ones you trade uh
you you trade you you have enough ones
so that you could trade up to get a good
quarterback next year
but i think overall mike i understand
exactly what you're saying
the best offer could well be by april
25th this year before the draft
but if they don't get what they want
what they think is fair market value for
something that
literally has never been on the trade
market
ever and that is a franchise quarterback
who's 25 years old and who
is playing at one of the highest levels
of
any quarterback young even though in
1987
he was 25 years old and got traded for a
two and a four
he was awful in tampa because in in
large part his supporting cast was awful
but what i'm saying is no one in history
has ever been this great this young
at the most important position and
gotten traded
so i i mean it's it's almost to me
unprecedented what the hall would be and
if i was a general manager i wouldn't
worry about the future
i would get my quarterback right now and
i would surround him
over the next few years with a team that
could win a super bowl
you've given me an idea you've given me
an idea that maybe
it may be a great idea or it may be
freaking nutty we'll se i'll let you
judge
here's my free advice to joe douglas and
he's guaranteed to get his money's worth
what i would do
today inspired by the conversation we
had just now
and a similar conversation we had on
friday if i'm joe douglas
i'm writing a letter today to nick
casario general manager of the texan
and john schneider general manager of
the seahawks
and i am outlining the terms of a trade
offer right
and it's up to them to bite and it's
it's one offer it's sam darnold plus the
second overall pick in the draft plus
the
jamal adams first round from the
seahawks this year and the jamal adams
first round from the seahawks next year
i'll go three ones and darnold
i put it on the table for both teams
whoever accepts
first gets it and then i sit back and
wait
either way i'm going to get to sean
watson i'm going to get russell wilson
or i'm going to get nobody but at least
i tried
um well that's an interesting
point i think what i would do if i were
trying to get
desean watson is i would offer
one more first round pick i wouldn't for
wilson i think wilson's 32 right if i'm
not mistaken
um yes and and look i'm not trying to be
stingy
if push came to shove i'd probably offer
a fourth one
for russell wilson but uh i think that's
a really
interesting idea i i kind of like
that idea in fact if if you're sure
if you're absolutely sure that
uh you uh you've
let's say there's only one thing that
would make me not do that mike
and that is if i was madly in love with
justin fields
if i was madly in love with justin
fields then
i trade darnold to indianapolis for as
much as i could get
and then uh i would draft justin fields
and i realized this might be impossible
but i would simply build the best
offensive line
that i could build uh you know over the
next say
two drafts and i would win that way
uh obviously you gotta do something with
your defense and get a playmaker there
but i think that's even more important
than getting a play playmaker
in the receiving core for the new york
jets
well i look a lot of it does come down
to whether or not the jets would prefer
watson
over russell wilson and that's
that that's a longer discussion because
there is the seven year
age difference but if if if you think
watson's the guy
the best way to leverage the texans to
give up watson
would be to make them realize there's
one trade that's going to be made by the
jets
and it's going to be a lot it's going to
be darnold plus the second overall pick
plus two more first round picks
and if the seahawks take it then it's
gone forever
there's there's got to be a way for
douglas to take the initiative here
and let's see and and it's it's the fact
that wilson
by all appearances is inching toward
wanting out
that turns it into not quite a
full-blown buyer's market but if deshawn
watson's the only
franchise quarterback who's currently
available
and then all of a sudden there's two of
them that gives the teams
looking to make the trade a little more
leverage it's just something to think
about if you're the jets you can play
this out a little bit more
and play the seahawks against the texans
and maybe get a little bit of a better
deal to get one of them done now both
quarterbacks have no trade clauses they
would individually have to want to go to
the jets to make it happen
but it's just it's something to it's
something to consider because these are
not going to be easy transactions
for anyone to work out because the
stakes are high the compensation is high
and uh we'll see how that plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports